welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question
this is the podcast that gives you too
much information about the real
cursed movies um not this candy-ass 2020
oh my movies keep getting delayed
[ __ ] curses
the movie curses that actually took
lives
and might take your life if you watch
them alone at night curses that might
live on to haunt the
avengers and game directors we'll be
talking about that i'm eric boss here
with me to say bloody mary three times
into a bathroom mirror is zach
huddleston hey buddy
hey eric i just i got my shot glass of
candy corns
and my uh delicious uh ice brewed coors
light so i'm
i'm ready to get spooky with you buddy
it's that time of year you got
everything you need tis the season
gobble gobble merry christmas
and happy valentine's well our big
question this week zach and zach and i
are going to tackle this one together
you want to hit us with a question zach
yes um so we've been asked this a couple
times and we also just love to talk
about this in general
what movies are truly cursed
um is that the production something
before after
there's a feels like there's a curse on
the movie hell yeah
because zach and i know from working in
this industry that there have been a lot
of films
you could argue all films are connected
with some kind of real life tragedy
the ones we we've talked a lot about uh
heath ledger of course died while
playing the joker in the dark knight
some believe it was connected to the
sleep deprivation that he went through
to prepare for that role
infamously one that really changed the
way movies are made
twilight zoned the movie in the 80s
director john landis
father of max landis that guy skirted
quite a few safety regulations on
production there weren't a lot of safety
regulations back then
uh sadly the star of that movie vic
morrow
shot a scene where there were two child
actors it was like a vietnam
setting there was a helicopter on the
set the helicopter pilot was instructed
to fly too low to stay in frame
lost control it was a horrific accident
the crash killed vic morrow and the two
kids
uh it was awful awful awful and the
event led to a lot of regulations and in
fact
every tv and film set whenever there's
miners on set they are required to be
accompanied by a studio teacher
it's something that like a lot of like
tv productions are like why do we have
to deal with this
you remind them it's because twilight
zone in the movie and um one of those
regulations is also if you have any
child
dolls on the set cursed or not they have
to have a
a teacher doll to watch them a teacher
doll that's right that's right there's
just a lot of dolls on every set
uh and some of them are cursed we're
gonna be talking about them this episode
because
uh some movies we believe are truly
cursed beyond what we just mentioned
truly creepy stories behind they're
making
really eerie coincidences that have
followed them in their whole franchise
history
coincidence i think not but you know
we're gonna try to stay respectful
because you know we have been told if
we're too jokey with this topic
especially when we talk about evil
spirits
the ghost of old man bechtold might
appear
but that's just a myth that's a myth
right it's it's a myth it's a myth that
there's a ghost that looks like tommy
bechtold though it's actually the spirit
of his great-grandfather tommy bechtold
though he's still wearing a jim kelly
jersey that's how you can tell
it's old man bechtold i've heard it's
just tommy astral projecting because he
sleeps so well in his helix mattresses
and it's really him well we'll find out
what's our first cursed film that we're
talking about i want to kick this off
with
one of the best both movies on our list
just as a good movie and
maybe one of the most cursed movies on
our list i'm talking about the exorcist
from 1973 and for those that haven't
seen it
hit pause on this go watch it it's such
a good movie
[Laughter]
but in that movie an actress daughter
played by linda blair
becomes possessed by a vulgar demon that
two priests attempt to exercise
directed by william friedkin who also
did the french connection a lot of other
great movies of the 70s
but there's a lot of spooky coincidences
and strange happenings
during the rome premiere of this movie
a 16th century church across the street
from the theater
was struck by lightning and the cross
fell to the ground
which i mean if getting struck if a
church getting struck by lightning says
anything i don't know if that's god's
mad at this movie or
satan's mad at this movie or both or god
was mad that they premiered it in rome
come on there's a lot of
roman catholic cardinals and bishops who
are probably praying against this movie
or they were rooting for it saying yes
this might make people go back to church
again i know
right like it certainly made a lot more
people believe in exorcism and
possession and things like that that the
catholic church technically does believe
he's part of the catechism yeah yeah of
christ
compels you oh does it does it compel me
some other uh strange or creepy
coincidences during filming
the sets burned down at night well
nobody was there nobody was harmed
but the only part of the set that was
completely untouched was the bedroom
set where the girl uh regan
uh experiences most of her demonic
possession
that's it i had heard of the set i had
heard of it burning down i didn't know
the room
was left untouched that's that's wild
that's
true it's wild if true wild if true
um there were at least nine deaths
associated with the production
including linda blair's grandfather two
actors who were kind of had
small parts in in the movie and max von
cider's brother
who died on the very first day of
filming he wasn't a part of the movie
but he died elsewhere
i will say the counter evidence to that
is max von sydow
lived like 50 more years after this
movie came out and like
just recently died at like age 190 so so
we had to watch
all of his friends and family die around
him zack that was a curse the true curse
of old age eric yes
it's been 84 years okay and then there
are a couple things and this is gonna be
a recurring theme for a couple of our
our movies here today
william friedkin the director maybe a
bit of an [ __ ]
not a great guy there's some stories out
of the 70s like a lot of like like your
francis ford coppola's and some of the
other big directors of the era
very ego driven very like my way or the
highway
and he did purposely a couple stunts in
this movie with ellen burstin
who played the mother and linda blair
who played the daughter that hurt them
and he wanted the stunts to look super
real and like maybe skirted some safety
issues or whatever
linda blair had a spinal injury and i
think ellen burstin had like a neck
injury
and they used those takes in the finals
that's so messed
up there's a scene you can look at that
where ellen bursting gets thrown against
a wall
and like kind of hits her head and her
reaction is legit because she's really
hitting her head
and it looks gnarly and then kind of the
scene where like
linda blair is like being like jerked up
and down she was like kind of on like a
hydraulic board and like the the safety
harness kind of got loose and she was
really being slammed against the board
and like
shedding real tears pretty gross you're
nasty there is a common theme of a
female actors
being the ones who directors like to
shock and use their takes they did this
with alien too
ridley scott sprayed one of the
actresses in the face with the blood
from
john hurt the chessburster scene and
it's like why do you have to why do you
think that's the only way i think it
shows like oh we don't trust women to
act
naturalistically so we have to like
shock them and scare them on set
it's like just trust your actors to do
their job please
god yes and in two movies we're not
going to talk about the kill bill
franchise and stanley kubrick's shining
have famous stories of those directors
not being very nice to their female
stars and kind of torturing them in the
name of art
um and then yeah here's the final the
final and creepiest
evidence of some kind of curse maybe
this is the the
origin of the curse on the exorcist
besides the general theme of
demonic possession the cast includes a
real-life
murderer that's right okay so there's a
scene where they take the girl to the
hospital
uh to have some tests done and william
friedkin went to the hospital to see
some of these tests be done and so he
used the real like doctors and
assistants
that he encountered in the scene so it's
a real doctor playing the doctor it's a
real like technician
the technician in the scene was this guy
paul bateson who's a real life medical
technician
who four years after this movie came out
admitted to killing his lover
who was a reporter and like called like
the newspaper and basically admitted it
and there's some thinking that he might
have killed other
people as well uh so he's just like he
showed up in uh
in mine hunters on netflix right he was
one of the people they interviewed yes
um in that show and in real life yeah
and again the
the pazuzu the demon that supposedly
possesses
the the daughter in this movie is a real
demon he was worshipped or feared or
whatever in in northern iran
you know millennia ago they've got real
like pazuzu
amulets and stuff like that that they've
dug in out of uh
the earth so some real stuff here as
long as we don't say that demon's name a
third time we may be okay
which demon pazuzu no
old man back told actually
you know what the holy water for old man
beg told ghost is of course light
of course so what what heck score would
you give the exorcist
pretty strong evidence eric all those
deaths and everything so i'm gonna give
it four out of five
hexes that's a pretty good score all
right i
uh want to move on to another one that
people say is cursed rosemary's baby
so if you haven't seen this one it's
also a great film to watch
made in 1968 by roman polanski and
very much connected to the history of
hollywood in some really dark ways
gotta go see it because it also is like
weirdly relevant
to now it's about a young wife played by
mia farrow who becomes pregnant under
mysterious circumstances
and she suffers gaslighting from her
husband from her neighbors until
spoiler warning for the ending of this
movie she she delivers a child who is
the eyes what you do to his eyes the
hell spawn of a satanic cult
oh god what a messed up creepy ending of
a film
so famously uh this film was considered
to be cursed producer william castle
suffered from a long and painful illness
that he blamed
on an angry letter that was sent to him
after the film's release
which might be a little thin but also
you got to take into account the film's
composer died of a mysterious brain
injury after the film ended but most
famously
the year after the film's release the
manson family
killed director roman polanski's wife
sharon tate
she's pregnant there were other people
who were murdered that night uh it's
documented in the well not really
documented it is depicted
uh or hinted at and then averted from
in once upon a time in hollywood also a
really amazing film they should check
out but uh
some kind of creepy lore around this the
actual head of the satanic church
anton levay was uh rumored to have
played the devil in the in the nightmare
sequence
uh at what point levi was friends with
susan atkins who is one of charles
manson's followers
but you know in the late 60s early 70s
there were a lot of people who were part
of the family
uh one of the beach boys was part of the
family boy
yeah dennis wilson
i'll also say eric just starting i i
found a lot of connections between some
of these cursed movies
the guy who plays the husband in this
movie john cassavetes
real life husband to ellen burstin who
played the mom and the exorcist
whoa eric so
how many hexes are you giving rosemary's
baby i'm gonna give it two out of five
hexes
just because i don't think anyone would
consider this movie cursed had the
uh the manson tape murders not happened
i think that was
one of the most horrific events in
hollywood history and then people just
backtracked
retconned associated it to rosemary's
baby also roman polanski's just
also a dirtbag human being so i think
that also is
attributed to a lot of this yes a
dirtbag human being who's still allowed
to make movies
so that guy hasn't been too cursed
moving on one of my favorite horror
movies for
all the wrong reasons 1976 is the omen
a classic the son of an ambassador the
ambassador's played by gregory peck
is secretly replaced at birth and then
freak accidents and all these crazy
violent deaths happen
until the family kind of comes to
finally way too late
realize that their son is the antichrist
damien
it's all for you oh the the
the death scenes in this movie are both
the cheesiest and some of the scariest
aim for the bushes
directed by superman 1-2 director
richard donner yeah the goonies guy yes
so some of the curse evidence for this
gregory peck the star of this movie
his son killed himself right before they
began
filming also gregory peck was on a plane
that was struck by lightning
the exact same thing happened to the
screenwriter when he was flying to the
set
both of their planes separately two
different planes were struck by
lightning
gregory peck almost boarded a plane at
another time during shooting
he didn't get on board immediately after
that plane crashed
and part of the lure behind that is the
plane like just got up off the runway
and then crashed onto a road
just kind of beyond the the runway um
killing everybody on board including the
pilot
the plane crashed into a car being
driven by the wife
of the pilot thus he both he died and he
killed his family
which is just an insane way and was uh
that they're a driver of ellen burstin
at some point can we also link it back
to them
on the radio they were playing an ellen
burst in soliloquy
no but um uh an animal handler there's a
great scene where they kind of go
through a safari park and all these
baboons attack the car and yeoman
and like one of the animal handlers on
the set like after filming rapt
was attacked and killed by a tiger some
of the reports say lion some say
tiger maybe it was a liger we can split
the difference but regardless
the man was killed and i think this is
my my favorite one just because of the
levels here and it's tough to beat the
airplane
which is crazy this one so the special
effects coordinator this is right after
the movie wrapped
was driving with his assistant slash
girlfriend they get in a car wreck
and through very similar circumstances
to a scene in the movie
the assistant girlfriend gets her head
cut off
she's decapitated famous scene in the
movie where a plane of glass cuts a
guy's head off
his head instantly turns into plastic
and looks like the fakest head that's
ever been
filmed but so she died the little tidbit
that puts this over the top
right next to the car crash there was a
road sign i think they were in
the netherlands at the time the road
sign was for a town
called omen o-m-m-e-n
and the distance to the town was 66.6
kilometers
no way that is
awful yes oh my god
that's a crazy one that's an insane one
and you know there was a something that
happened with this movie the exorcist
a couple of the movies we're gonna talk
about like it can be hard to separate
the pr
campaign and like maybe the studio kind
of goosing some of these scary stories
to get audiences out
but with the omen there was a lot around
it like they had a minister uh his name
was robert munger who was like an
advisor on the film
and he famously said all this stuff
about like you know
the devil doesn't want you to make this
movie he's gonna come for you
because he doesn't like that you're
using his name so much or something like
that uh
he wants to stay in the shadows and
you're exposing him yeah
though i've also heard the counter
argument that maybe the devil loved this
movie
because though there's all these crazy
things happening like gregory peck
didn't get on the plane
that crashed and oh richard donner's uh
hotel got bombed by the ira
in london that just happened yeah that
just happened
to be here they were bombing lots of
hotels at the time yeah but he was
unharmed and nobody in the cast was
harmed
so it's like maybe the devil was
protecting
this movie interesting
for all those reasons and just for the
incredible
silly gore of the omen i give this movie
three out of five hexes
fair score right in the middle there's
enough evidence there that
that definitely creeps me out the next
one i'm gonna bring to you zach
is uh the conjurine annabelle
nunn series the james one uh horror film
universe
so this uh initially with the contouring
followed paranormal investigators ed and
lorraine warren
who were real people in the movie
they're played by patrick wilson and
uh vera farmiga they explore various
hauntings um but as the film universe
expands we
uh one actually starts in the cold open
with the doll annabelle but then we we
follow annabelle in her own film series
that's the doll the haunted doll
and then uh the nun uh the nun is the
the latest wrinkle of this universe
so throughout these films there have
been various claims
so vera farmiga has claimed that a ghost
left
claw marks on her laptop while filming
which is interesting
she saw it on her screen and she thinks
it was it was associated so also in the
conjuring
uh the day that the real family that the
film was based on so this was a family
that was in this house
and that real family visited the set
crew members reported that a gust of
wind followed them
everywhere they went which
i don't know i i've talked to some
teamsters in my life they're full of
stories
because most of the time they're not
working they're just kind of like
yeah we know where he's buried but
it does remind you of if you saw that
movie saw the trailer with the more
memorable moments
the wind kept blowing the laundry sheet
and then it caught on something
it's hurt so maybe that that's kind of
the peril there
so onset of annabelle director john
leonetti
claims that he saw three fingers drawn
through dust on the set
over and over again and the reason it's
creepy the the demonic doll
has three fingers and he's saying that
he kept seeing
like as it would come to life and just
drag its fingers and leave its mark
everywhere
um also during annabelle a glass light
fixture fell
on the actor playing the demon in the
same hallway
in which the demon kills the gender in
the movie
[Music]
and then while filming the nun uh the
director claims to have seen
two men in a room who disappeared when
he turned back to them
so it could just be other associated
ghosts or it could be really sneaky
uh teamsters who are looking for a place
to lounge
that's probably more likely well and i
like of all the movies we're talking
about
this is the only one that is grounded in
some kind of reality obviously they take
some liberties but these are real people
and real events being depicted in these
movies so there's some like
potential for real ghosts being involved
right the history is being disturbed and
now they're trying to keep the story
from getting out i will say though when
you're on a film set or a tv set zach
and i both worked on these there's lots
of little hidden entrances and exits
because they're all built to be
uh ersatz and fake so you could just
kind of be like oh here's the sneaky
little spot
as a pa i my first job in ndpa says like
where are the best places to take a nap
where they won't be able to see you
you find those spots you take a nap and
then people don't know they exist
also maybe when you're filming a scary
movie
you're more aware of these things when
you're just you know doing the
voice over for trolls world tour you
know you don't notice that your laptop
got scratched you know what i mean you
just
take it for granted you think your your
cat came in and wanted to do a little
keyboard cat action
but still um maybe it's because it's
more recent uh
and things in the 70s and 80s and 60s
were scarier but i'm going to grade the
rumored hauntings uh the curse of the
conjuring series
one out of five hexes but room to grow
that's right i mean
somebody keep an eye on vera farmiga
okay
if some bad stuff happens to her patrick
wilson then that score is going to go
way up
speaking of bad stuff happening to great
actors our next movie 1993's
the crow and now to young zach this was
a formative
film loved this movie loved the
mythology around this movie
it's about a man who gets kind of killed
wrongly
played by brandon lee comes back from
the dead to kind of be this kind of
spirit of vengeance
has some similarities to a ghost rider
or whatever
this very iconic black and white face
makeup
that has kind of been co-opted by
juggalo and other cultures
uh since then some say it inspired heath
ledger's makeup and
as joker yes yeah and some of the
fashion there's a lot of like black
leather and latex in this movie
certainly we see some connections maybe
to the matrix and some other proto-goth
stuff that came after it
but the evidence for the curse of this
film is mostly centered around the star
brandon lee son of martial arts legend
bruce lee
who died in an onset accident where
um i always growing up i always heard
that it was a real bullet placed in a
prop gun that's actually not true it was
a
part of a prop bullet got lodged in the
barrel
of a gun and then when another prop
bullet kind of shot through it
this chunk of metal which basically
formed a bullet
lodged into brandon lee's chest
struck an aorta killed him terrible
right and it kind of plays into this
idea of the lee family curse
his father bruce lee died pretty young
uh while his kind of star was still on
the rise just like brandon lee
and also kind of of unusual
circumstances like he had kind of a
brain
injury some people think it was because
he'd recently had his
sweat glands removed so he looked cooler
while filming
hmm oh whoa very strange but there's all
these conspiracies about the chinese
mafia put a hit on him blah blah
the curse of bruce lee also one of the
strangest
kind of coincidences between their
deaths the movie bruce lee was filming
when he died
featured a plot point where an actor
played by bruce lee
is shot by a guy who puts a real bullet
into a prop gun
right killing him on the side and that's
basically what happened
to his son during his final film
wow yeah there were some other kind of
accidents on set a hurricane damaged
some sets an electrician was kind of
very badly burned but like
truly you know the tragedy of brandon
lay who seemed like he was about to kind
of take off and maybe
could have kind of mirrored some of that
keanu reeves
90s into 2000s kind of action adventure
kind of movies you know so i i'll say
maybe because it doesn't loom as large
in our culture this film
and you know it's kind of most of the
curses built around this one poor guy
one out of five hoaxes
um one out of five hexes uh
for the crowd yeah that's that's a dark
tale okay i
i have one more on my list zach and to
me i think this is
the most truly cursed film that we're
talking about this episode
you know what it is 1982's
so this is a film that has so many
interesting things about it it was uh
directed by tobe hooper but it's
believed that steven spielberg actually
shot this movie this movie
and e.t came out the same summer steven
spielberg had a contract with universal
that was ironclad did not let him work
on other stuff but
poltergeist was a story that he helped
develop he wrote the script to it
it was uh near and dear to his heart he
wanted to also direct this movie
so he had top uber directed he's also a
township director but
in the years since a lot of the cast is
like yes spielberg directed
most of this movie most of the shots you
see were spielberg shots
anyway the story it became a whole
franchise after the fact uh but the
original story is about a daughter carol
anne gets uh trapped in another
dimension within the house by
these evil forces they're here family
freaks out
uh they find out that the house spoiler
warning
was built atop these graves you moved
the bodies but they didn't move the
headstones did you
know you moved the cemetery but you
didn't move the bodies
you did move the bodies you only moved
the headstones
not getting right i did just watch that
movie but i i because there's so many
iconic moments the teenage daughter
what's happening
it starts out like charming that's
what's creepy about it it starts out
like
fun family charming stuff that and
you're
you know deep down you're like there's
something not right about this the whole
house goes ape [ __ ] and eventually gets
sucked into a void one of the
best climaxes of a film but so many dark
things
happened around the poltergeist
franchise so both the daughters of this
family died
untimely deaths we'll start with uh
dominique dunn she was a teenage
daughter dana
uh was tragically strangled by her
boyfriend
shortly after the first movie had
wrapped she went into a coma died five
days
later the boyfriend this piece of [ __ ]
was only convicted
of voluntary manslaughter served three
and a half years
in prison the judge was just every
possible way he could be an [ __ ] they
brought in another past girlfriend of
his who said that he assaulted her
but he threw out all that testimony and
the judge
himself later admitted that he picked up
and that the guy should have served
longer
that's the uh you know judicial system
that we had
and still have but um even
more terrifyingly heather work uh died
due to a misdiagnosed intestinal issue
during the filming of the third film she
was still so young
but sadly that is something that like
this is why we need to really look out
for the welfare of child actors because
a lot of them
they just they're worked to death
in some cases and they they are just
looked at as ways to make money
and i'm not saying that's not what
happened here but it is like part of an
issue where a lot of child actors
are just like their health and
well-being is not really looked after
but really eerily the brother robbie has
a poster for super bowl
22 in his room which i think is insane
because the movie came out in
82 super bowl 22 came out six years
later
in 1988 so why do they have a future
super bowl poster in his room
some prop master didn't know how to do
roman numerals right
yeah maybe but what's even crazier about
that heather o'rourke
caroline died the day after super bowl
six years later in san diego that was
the same city
where that game took place
now the reason why a lot of people say
this is cursed so the movie of course
uh the reason why people believe it was
haunted is that it was these
home developments were built on
cemeteries and they didn't move the
bodies
well the first movie used actual
human remains in the final sequence at
the time
apparently realistic looking prosthetics
were not widely available
and would have been super costly to
construct so the special effects team
the makeup artist craig reardon himself
testified under oath in an unrelated
lawsuit about authorship of the script
he testified under oath that they got 13
skeletons
real human skeletons from india via a
medical supply company
wow that's a low price and then they
just touched up the remains to make them
look more degraded
and like emaciated and gross and like
still covered with sinew and flesh
which to be fair there is a long history
of this in hollywood right like
obviously before like the advent of like
easy replicas like in in the movie
frankenstein they use a real skeleton
like there's been
like in basically any horror movie made
before the 80s
if you see a skeleton there's a good
chance those are real human bones
doesn't make it any less creepy
[Music]
and what's super gross about it you'll
remember the scene the the mom
goes into the dugout swimming pool and
then the
the bones float up and it freaks her out
she at the time as a young actress
thought that they were prosthetics she
thought they were props they didn't tell
her those were real bones she just
didn't think to ask
and later she found out about it was
super creeped out and a lot of people
associate the
the curse around this film to be related
to the fact that they used
13 real human skeletons in the
production of this in a story about how
you should not disturb
human remains but the actress jobeth
williams uh said that everyone was so
creeped out
and the sequels they had the co-star
will sampson who is a real-life member
of the muskogee creek nation they had to
perform an exorcism on the set in the
second movie
um just to put everyone at ease but
years later
crew members in the 1990 film ghost
claimed to have heard footsteps and a
child's laughter
on the set which we found out later was
the same sound stage
that heather o'rourke had shot on
shortly before her death
the actor of a cursed film cursing
another film
is the snake eating its own tale of
cursed films
is it not right i believe it is and
we'll see how this develops because
in april 2019 they announced that they
are rebooting
the poltergeist franchise with directors
of avengers end game
the russo brothers behind it so zach do
you think that curse will follow them
well i hope not because i enjoy the work
of the russo brothers uh which
which avenger would you cast in a
poltergeist reboot eric
i think it's got to be mark ruffalo that
guy no one can show confusion and
bewilderment on his face like ruffalo
[Music]
he's the modern day craig t nelson
anyways isn't he yeah oh absolutely
all right and i am going to score this
five out of five hexes just because
of uh the tragic deaths that have
surrounded it and
the fact that we have proof that they
did actually something very creepy on
the production
uh i feel like that's gotta be connected
it's a metaphysical way
absolutely as we close out this segment
eric i will
kiss this button i took from your coat
the last time i saw you in person
next you'll be coming to me begging for
help
will someone put a thinner curse on me
please i've uh
gained quite a bit of weight but one way
that i try to keep the calories off you
loving the segway
you loving this segue yeah is by
drinking a nice
light beer
even though these days we're not
technically going anywhere that doesn't
mean that life
doesn't feel go go go as we switch from
doom scrolling on social media
to zoom meetings uh to family
obligations it's a lot we gotta deal
with a lot
sometimes zach i know how you feel we
gotta just turn it off and when we do
we reach for the beard that is made to
chill of course light
thanks of course light for sponsoring
course light is brewed with a three-step
cold process
cold lagered cold filtered and cold
packaged so it's actually
made to chill you know eric i had one of
these
special cans too that like the mountains
turn blue when it gets cold enough yeah
you can still it's it's been open for a
little while now but you can still see
their blue here and that's how i
knew it was time to pop this bad boy i
do believe and and this is not
intentional i do have a larger beer than
you eric that's not a reflection
of my manhood in comparison to yours or
my thirst or anything like that so i
just happened to be the one i got
do you think maybe he's compensating for
something
it means i'm a bigger man and to me the
drinks look real small i'm a big
tall paul bunyan with my cancer beer man
the mountains look so small to me
look at those hands are they small hands
look that's why coors light is the one
we choose when we need a moment of chill
so
when you want to reset reach for the
beer that's made to chill
you can have coors light delivered by
going to coorslight.com
and finding a local delivery option near
you remember celebrate responsibility
coors brewing company golden colorado
oh also zach have you seen uh the social
dilemma documentary on netflix
i've heard so many people talk about it
but no i haven't gotten to it yet oh you
you got to watch it this was
such a terrifyingly illuminating
experience for
for me so in the movie uh you learned
these tech insiders explain how social
media
is specifically engineered to exploit
users data
for profit they call it surveillance
capitalism that is exactly what it is
look uh you know i may be cool with
normal capitalism
but uh i don't want my data being
harvested so tech billionaires can get
richer and richer and i get nothing out
of that
other than people like knowing me and
putting me in the code form into their
algorithm
so they can kind of predict my habits in
a very creepy way
so that is why i put an extra layer of
protection around my data with
expressvpn you didn't see that coming so
every time you use the internet big tech
companies mine your data by tracking
your searches your messages
your video history but when you run
expressvpn on your device it
hides your ip address which websites can
use to personally identify you
it hides it so that it makes your
activity more difficult to trace and
sell to those evil advertisers that are
out there
you still need to be careful with what
you share on social media but expressvpn
can make your web browsing more
anonymous as it should be x-ray cpn also
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers
and all kinds of prying eyes many vpns
will slow down your internet but not
expressvpn it is incredibly
fast and easy to use just tap one button
and you are
protected so if you don't like the idea
of tech companies exploiting your
personal information then visit
expressvpn.com
big q right now and you can get three
months of expressvpn for free that is
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
big q to protect your data go to
expressvpn.com
bigqueue to learn more okay now we're
gonna move on to our
question that i'm gonna answer what is
it this week zack we got actually a
physical letter from
uh viewer lindsay who i think does it
does a great job
uh doing some doctor strange cosplay
that we might link to here but
she asked this very important scientific
question
eric okay all right do the massive
biological changes that happen to our
favorite heroes
impact the magnitude of their farts
okay and what is the possibility of
their farts causing any kind of damage
excellent question i'm so glad you asked
well
we did find this marvel toy game called
operation hulk
in which the cover of the box depicts a
it's like operation but with hulk
uh there's a deadly green gas coming out
of his butt with a skull and crossbones
and blind canonically that hulk's farts
are deadly
so you gotta be careful we couldn't find
evidence of this in the comics maybe
it's out there somewhere we couldn't
find it but i guess the question is
do we measure fart damage by like
pungency of the odor
or amount of the gas release the force
with which the blast
comes out of his booty hole
i mean what is fart damage that is the
ultimate big question i think i mean it
certainly damaged some relationships
i've been in
[Music]
a lot of road trips ruined by uh damage
oh hey what the hell couple elevator
rides
[Music]
okay let's talk about how flatulence
works uh biologically it's a normal
process they believe that most people
should be farting about 10 times a day
so you know
all your girlfriends out there say they
don't fart they are ripping it you know
a decade at a time so be smart know your
farts and let them rip
really it happens when our bodies
swallow air naturally whenever we're
eating or drinking
uh that air builds up also when we eat
foods that are difficult to digest
uh it releases a gas that builds up and
if you think about it hulk eats what we
eat he just eats a lot more of it we saw
that huge
breakfast in avengers end game he's also
constantly snacking he's eating ice
cream which i don't know about you zach
but when i
eat ice cream or dairy mmm clear the
room
also i thought about this when that guy
is jumping battle to battle
he is roaring he is taking in all kinds
of air as he leaps
i have to assume that would result in
more air trapped in his digestive system
but i don't know if the farts themselves
should smell any worse since it is the
same food being broken down with the
same enzymes in his digestive system
which i assume from the fact that at no
point in the mcu do it
was just really anyone complaining about
hulk's natural bo
so they never say oh he stinks he's
stinky so i would assume that he
probably has a comparable
metabolism to a normal human so i would
say that his farts
don't smell any worse but there is more
gas released
when he farts so it'll take it longer
for the air to clear and uh and and
dissipate
however i don't know the mechanics of
his sphincter in his butt cheeks
but if his butt cheeks were to
thunderclap when he farts
we know from our thunderclaps episode
that could level a planet
wow that's true right put out forest
fires uh
explode people's brains and their skulls
like all from a fart
i also want to point out when bruce
becomes hulk
basically everything just gets bigger we
can assume like his stomach enlarges
and like all of his organs his his bones
his body tissue just expands
and now this doesn't impact current mcu
hulk who's permanently hulk but like
kind of the classic canonical hulk when
he goes back into being bruce
everything shrinks back down but not
the gas molecules in his stomach so when
hulk turns back into bruce he's got to
be ripping
one of them yeah steady stream of fart
you know
like that's why he had to walk over that
hill in age of ultron is really he was
just trying to walk it off crop dusted
on the other side of those trees
we often see him holding like some
shredded pants we don't see what
happened to the seat of the pants
you know i think if he were to
thunderclap a fart he
must have uh some control in order for
that to be the case because not just any
time hulk claps his hands he has to like
aggressively intentionally bring his
hands together to create
that uh that shock wave so when i fart
i'm not thinking about
the the friction of my butt uh i'm not
controlling it it just happened you've
never been in like a hot tub and tried
to replicate one of the jets or
something oh i can i can pour this one
out i just can't control how it comes
out i'll say it that way
uh we should move on to our final box of
scraps
20 more minutes of hulk farts
[Laughter]
bunch of scraps right it has to happen
our box of scraps we're going to stay on
the theme of curses so zach our our box
scraps question this week have you
ever felt like you were cursed well this
is a little late in the episode to
acknowledge this but i don't believe in
curses or ghosts
or or blessings or angels or really
anything that's not um eric vos in the
new rockstars channel
everything else could be made up um
so i i don't know that i necessarily
feel felt cursed but maybe the closest
i've ever
feeling cursed there was a particular a
six-month window
where really my life kind of got turned
upside down for a variety of reasons
this was not too long ago
you knew me during this period but like
i worked at a theater
that closed uh shortly thereafter a
four-year relationship
ended and so i then i also had to move
out
and i kind of like lost a beloved pet
dog in the
in the transaction or the moving out and
i happened to move into a place not
knowing these were
i i had a roommate who somebody i didn't
know who turned out to be a drug addict
which was just like those are none of
those things individually
are totally insane or um oh my god i'm
cursed
but the fact that they all happened
maybe within like a four month span
also the drug addict overdosed while i
lived
uh with him and and his dog died
which is again it was just it was just a
lot it was just a lot and then i
got the other side and now everything's
great but um that that might be the
the period where if if there had been a
curse placed on me if i had struck a
roma woman um accidentally with my car
maybe while backing out of a trader
joe's
that would have been the period of time
in which she could have cursed me
possibly
how about you eric have you ever felt
cursed i had a similar
uh transitory period in my life i uh as
you know my apartment burned down in
2015.
um but that week days before that i got
in the
you know knock on wood only car accident
i've ever been in in my life only
time where there was like a moving
collision uh where someone just cut me
off she thought i was parked i was
clearly in a turn lane
uh and she clipped my car and it was a
super stressful period i'm like this
will be the most stressful thing that
happens this week and no no no
my home burned down four days later
uh it was caused by a uh i mean it was a
foreseeable thing for sure the the
firefighters are like yeah we're waiting
for this to happen
because there was a construction site
that was right adjacent to our building
feet away
that had been there in the dry hot sun
of drought southern california and they
brought in some dudes to tear it down
they weren't being careful they let some
sparks fly into some some sawdust
uh the whole thing went ablaze and it
scorched our building i had to move out
of it
but that's not the craziest thing a
month before that
my godmother's home burned down as well
in mississippi
um which honestly the curse here is the
fact that we live
on a cooking planet in which
droughts happen that dry up things and
there's all kinds of construction
oversight that these things are just
bound to happen more and more
anyway um but then yeah that whole
summer was a very uh dark period for my
family we had a cousin who passed away
like a couple weeks after that um many
people in my family believe that there
was some kind of dark curse on our
family
uh for that period of time i thought the
curse was lifted because on the other
side of it
i i met a girl and we started dating and
i think
part of the reason she she felt for me
was i had written a whole blog about my
story of like
how i thought there was a curse on the
family we got along fine but then like a
couple months later zach i found out
that she was a 911 truther so i think
the curse was still on
oh yeah just just when you think you're
out of the curse
that's when the curse truly strikes
she's like you want to talk about fires
let's talk about the control demolitions
that happen in the north tower
no she didn't say that she said she's
actually a very nice person she just
believes certain
anti-vaxxer and 9 11 truth or conspiracy
theories it's fine it's fine i wish
you're the best
but anyway so yeah i don't know if i
believe in curses but
as you do probably zack i do believe in
when it rains it pours
yes good things come in bunches and bad
things do the same yeah
just how it happens well uh let us know
if you have been cursed down below
we'd love to talk more about these kind
of things on new rockstars other than
just
superhero theories but on that that is
our show this week zach it has been
wonderful to talk about the terrifying
real history of hollywood with you
thank you absolutely always a blast eric
when you have me on the show uh
thank you to the ghost of tommy bechtold
the first for allowing us to complete
this episode
yes thank you and uh please stay out of
my dreams tonight
please a reminder to all of you watching
that you can join our official discord
server by becoming a patron
at patreon.comrockstars there you can
submit questions that's where we first
see all of our big question submissions
you can also get an audio version of the
show by subscribing to rockstar's
question wherever you get your podcast
and also you can tweet questions
on twitter using the hashtag bigquestion
follow me at eavos follow zach at
z huddleston follow me rockstars and
social subscribe here on youtube to get
too much information on all the stuff
you care about
including the astral projected forms of
mr old man back told
go bills if you say go bills three times
you won't bother you
go all right we're covered we're good
we're good we're good see ya
[Music]
ah